You'll have to acknowledge that
shakespeare was a little,
one of the primary inventors of the
language we use today.
He was a fountainhead of phrases and
words and so on.
Then we now take for granted,
uh,
of course the other great shaper of our
language languages,
the,
um,
the King James version of the Bible,
but it has a poultry vocabulary compared
with the Shakespeare's fountain of
explosive found in other words.
Uh,
so he did,
you know,
in terms of,
just giving us the means to communicate.
He's,
he's a godfather.
Um,
I think he is acknowledged as one of the
greatest dramatists ever.
The fact that the Russians claim him the
French,
the Germans or whatever,
that he's,
he's not English or American.
He is this universal,
a playwright speaking,
invoicing,
extraordinary truths because he seems to
have the finger on the pulse of what
makes people tick.
Um,
he's fascinated by the human condition.
and yet you have to put it back.
He was also in a writing plays for
actors to perform.
And so the formula is very,
um,
he's extraordinary because he's in the
same play that he can,
you know,
for people who are maybe a little more
educated,
have the essays,
have bacon in the park,
pocket's going to wash a shakespeare
play.
They will get this wonderful existential
examination of,
you know,
what is man,
and what's the point,
where are we going?
And,
uh,
you know,
what his death,
uh,
all these wonderful issues in the same
play that an ignorant,
uneducated,
a citizen can pay as penny stand in the
rain and watch a play about armies and
witches and poisonings and revenge and
so on.
He absolutely gets his money's worth.
So he's has this wonderful ability to,
to encompass all these interests.
I think for the actor also,
he is one of the most generous of
authors because,
um,
he doesn't want you to,
you don't have to,
do,
you know,
what the author intended because you're
never quite sure with shakespeare what
he intends,
he sort of supplies great situations,
extraordinary words,
but he wants your collaboration.
He wants your input.
Uh,
and uh,
it's,
it's always a,
uh,
teamwork.
You know,
there's,
there's not a definitive thing that you
have to do that makes it a shakespeare
in performance or Shakespeare and hamlet
and it's not what he wants.
And that's,
I think the reason why he's endured for
so long and why every country sees him
as the playwright and Whitefield go on
being performed because he's,
he's,
yes,
he's language has changed over the
years.
And uh,
um,
the fact that he's all his,
uh,
you know,
the phrases that you use or they're not
pretentious and highfaluting and poetic,
that the imagery is all from chairs and
tables and glasses and whatever.
The things that can people relate to,
you know,
he doesn't talk in a self conscious
poetic terms.
Yeah.
Because he was being made an academic
subject which he would have hated.
But once you get a,
if the class was made to perform a play
to,
you know,
to actually,
uh,
you know,
inhabit the roles and make them live.
Once you get behind it,
it's amazing.
And kids get Shakespeare.
Um,
they,
uh,
he's very,
very user friendly.
I think if you're a young person
growing up a adolescent and you play
Hamlet,
I'm there all sorts of things that you
relate to and it's all about
relationships with parents and the
loyalties and friends,
school friends,
uh,
um,
what's it all about,
you know,
um,
love,
in relationships with women.
It's,
well,
lots of things that relate to.
And the other thing about Shakespeare is
that the language is very,
as I said,
it's very easy to learn in a way because
again,
shakespeare was a genius and he
constructs language in such a way that,
you know,
inhabits an actor's mind very
comfortably.
And by the same token,
it's very difficult to unlearn because
I'm rattles around and uh,
and it sort of fertilizers the language.
You find yourself speaking,
you know,
using shakespeare and phrases all the
time.
I come from a British group,
a
tradition,
and I think no British actor considers
himself a true actor unless he has
shakespeare under his belt.
Not just because it's a but because it's
a practical thing,
but he is the best.
Uh,
and he,
you know,
if you,
if you perform shakespeare,
you know,
you learn great things about breath
control.
He's a,
and I think he is so often misunderstood
in this country,
uh,
where the method tradition is very
strong.
You know,
this especially in movies,
fantastic for movies,
useless for Shakespeare because so many
actors feel that they are to a,
instead of just playing the role,
you know,
the best acting,
I'm less than is there.
And Hamlet,
by the way,
at the mouth,
rather cheeky prince tells these
professional actors how they should,
you know,
how,
how they should perform this play.
And it's really behind hamlet.
That's Shakespeare imploring actors for
this new style.
But he's creating,
you know,
speak the speech.
I pray you as I pronounced it to you,
trippingly on the tongue,
but if you over it as many of your
players do I have this leaf.
The town crier spoke my lines.
No,
did not solve the air too much with your
hands.
That's but use all gently be not to tame
neither,
but let your own discretion be your
tutors,
sued the reaction to the word,
the word to the action with this special
observance,
that step,
not the modesty of nature for anything.
So,
uh,
don is from the purpose of playing who's
an both of the fest and now was and is
to hold as to where the mirror up to
nature to show veteran feature on her
own image and the very age and body of
the time,
his form and pressure.
It goes on a bit.
Nothing's changed.
What else do you need?
No,
it's a question.
Are we better off if we know exactly who
shakespeare was?
Are we to accept this stratfordian
candidate who for my money is a little
unlikely?
There's a man who could barely write his
name,
who was,
whose wife was illiterate,
who own notebooks and nothing was spoken
about him in his lifetime.
It's a,
it seems that William Shrugs,
pair of,
uh,
of water is not the brilliant genius,
the William Shake Hyphen Spear Elizabeth
and giveaway for a pseudonym,
um,
who wrote these plays and,
I'm my own feeling as a candidate.
The earl of Oxford airport to veer is
highly plausible,
but the smoking gun that will link him,
you know,
whereas a lot of evidence but are way
better off knowing who he is.
I'll be just,
you know,
well off just having the,
um,
you know,
what he wrote to go.